for most of history the overwhelming
majority of the earth's inhabitants have
owned more or less nothing the clothes
they stood up in some bowls a pot and a
pan perhaps a broom and if things were
going really well a few farming
implements nations and peoples remained
consistently poor global gdp did not
grow at all from year to year the world
was in aggregate as hard up in 1800 as
it had been at the beginning of time
however starting in the early 18th
century in the countries of northwestern
europe a remarkable phenomenon occurred
economies began to expand and wages to
rise families who'd never before had any
money beyond what they needed just to
survive found they could go shopping for
small luxuries a comb or a mirror a
spare set of underwear a pillow some
thicker boots or a towel
their expenditure created a virtuous
economic cycle the more they spent the
more businesses grew the more wages rose
by the middle of the 18th century
observers recognize that they were
living through a period of epochal
change that historians have since
described as the world's first consumer
revolution it was in britain where the
changes were most marked enormous new
industries sprang up to cater for the
widespread demand for goods that had
once been the preserve of the very rich
alone in england cities you could buy
furniture from chippendale heppel white
and sheraton pottery from wedgwood and
derby cutlery from the smitherees of
sheffield and hats shoes and dresses
featured in the best-selling magazines
like the gallery of fashion and the
ladies magazine
styles for clothes and hair which had
formally gone unchanged for decades now
altered every year often in extremely
theatrical and impractical directions
in the early 1770s there was a craze for
decorated wigs so tall that tops could
only be accessed by standing on a chair
it was fun for the cartoonists so vivid
and numerous with the consumer novelties
that the austere dr johnson riley
wondered whether prisoners were also
soon to be hanged in a new way
the christian church looked on and did
not approve up and down england
clergymen delivered bitter sermons
against the new materialism they called
it vanity which was a sin
sons and daughters were to be kept away
from shops god would not look kindly on
those who paid more attention to
household decoration than the state of
their souls
but they now emerged an intellectual
revolution that sharply altered the
understanding of the role of vanity in
an economy in 1723 a london physician
called bernard mandeville published an
economic tract titled the fable of the
bees which proposed that contrary to
centuries of religious and moral
thinking what made countries rich and
therefore safe honest generous spirited
and strong was a very minor unelevated
and apparently undignified activity
shopping for pleasure it was the
consumption of what mandeville called
fripperies hats bonnets gloves butter
dishes soup terence shoehorns and hair
clips that provided the engine for
national prosperity and allowed the
government to do in practice what the
church only knew how to sermonize about
in theory make a genuine difference to
the lives of the weak and the poor the
only way to generate wealth argued
mandeville was to ensure high demand for
absurd and unnecessary things of course
no one needed embroidered handbags silk
line slippers or ice creams but it was a
blessing that they could be prompted by
fashion to want them for on the back of
demand for such trifles workshops could
be built apprentices trained and
hospitals funded mandeville shocked his
audience with the starkness of the
choice he placed before them a nation
could either be very high-minded
spiritually elevated intellectually
refined and dirt poor
or a slave to luxury and idle
consumption and very rich
mandeville's dark thesis went on to
convince almost all the great anglophone
economists and political thinkers of the
18th century
there were nevertheless some occasional
departures from the new economic
orthodoxy one of the most spirited and
impassioned voices was that of
switzerland's greatest philosopher
jean-jacques russo
shocked by the impact of the consumer
revolution on the manners and atmosphere
of his native geneva he called for a
return to a simpler older way of life of
the sword he had experienced in alpine
villages or read about in travellers
accounts of the native tribes of north
america
in the remote corners of appenzell or
the vast forests of missouri there was
blessedly no concern for fashion and no
one-upmanship around hair extensions
russo recommended closing geneva's
borders and imposing crippling taxes on
luxury goods so that people's energies
could be redirected towards non-material
values
he looked back with fondness to the
austere martial spirit of sparta however
even if russo disagreed with mandeville
he did not seek to deny the basic
premise behind his analysis it truly
appeared to be a choice between
decadent consumption and wealth on the
one hand and virtuous restraint and
poverty on the other it was simply that
russo unusually preferred virtue to
wealth
the parameters of this debate have
continued to dominate economic thinking
ever since we re-encounter them in
ideological arguments between
capitalists and communists and free
marketeers and environmentalists but for
most of us the debate is no longer
pertinent we simply accept that we will
live in consumer economies with some
very unfortunate side effects to them
crass advertising foodstuffs that are
unhealthy for us products that are
disconnected from any reasonable
assessment of our needs all this in
exchange for economic growth and high
employment we have chosen wealth over
virtue
an irony laden acceptance of this
dichotomy is what underpins the approach
of many pop artists in mid-20th century
america for example kleis oldenburg
developed a reputation for taking modest
consumer items many of them food-related
and reproducing them at enormous scale
usually in outdoor settings in vibrant
polyester or vinyl in city squares where
one might once have expected to find
statues in honour of political leaders
or religious saints one now came across
outsized hamburgers giant cheesecakes
huge fries decked with ketchup or
perhaps oldenburg's most famous work a
12 meter high stainless steel inverted
ice cream cone oldenburg's vast versions
of small things playfully directed our
attention to the peculiar dependence of
modern economies on the mass consumption
of what are in human terms some deeply
negligible products yet the scale of
oldenberg's objects was only
superficially absurd because it rather
precisely reflected their actual
importance in our collective economic
destinies nevertheless as oldenburg
seemed to concede it was peculiar to be
living in a civilization founded on the
back of buns and sweetened tomato paste
a bathhouse hinted at by the deflated
detumescent appearance of many of the
giant burgers hot dogs and pizzas
the one question that's rarely been
asked is whether there might be a way to
attenuate the dispiriting choice to draw
on the best aspects of consumerism on
the one hand and high-mindedness on the
other without suffering there were sides
moral decadence and profound poverty
might it be possible for a society to
develop that allows for consumer
spending and therefore provides
employment and welfare yet of a kind
directed at something other than
vanities and superfluities
might we shop for something other than
nonsense in other words might we have
wealth and a degree of virtue it is this
possibility of which we find some
intriguing hints in the work of adam
smith an 18th century economist too
often read as a blunt apologist for all
aspects of consumerism but in fact one
of its more subtle and visionary
analysts in his book the wealth of
nations published in 1776 adam smith
seems at points willing to concede to
key aspects of mandeville's argument
consumer societies do help the poor by
providing employment based around
satisfying what are often rather
sub-optimal purchases smith was as ready
as other economists to mock the
triviality of some consumer choices
while admiring their consequences all
those embroidered lace handkerchiefs
dual snuff boxes and miniature temples
made of cream for dessert they were
flippant he conceded but they encouraged
trade created employment and generated
immense wealth and could therefore be
firmly defended on this score alone
however smith held out some fascinating
hopes for the future he pointed out that
consumption didn't invariably have to
involve the trading of frivolous things
he had seen the expansion of the
edinburgh book trade and knew how large
a market higher education might become
he understood how much wealth was being
accumulated through the construction of
edinburgh's extremely handsome and noble
newtown he understood that humans have
many higher needs that require a lot of
labor and intelligence and work to
fulfill but that lie outside of
capitalist enterprise as conceived of by
realists like bernard mandeville among
these our need for education for
self-understanding for beautiful cities
and for rewarding social lives the
ultimate goal of capitalism and adam
smith's view was to tackle happiness in
all its complexities psychological and
not just merely material
the capitalism of our times still hasn't
entirely come round to resolving the
awkward choices that bernard mandeville
and joshua rousseau circled but the
crucial hope for the future is that we
may not forever need to be making money
off rather exploitative silly or vain
consumer appetites that we may also
learn to generate enormous profits from
helping people as consumers and
producers in the truly important and
ambitious aspects of their lives the
reform of capitalism hinges on an odd
sounding but critical task a new kind of
consumerism the conception of an economy
focused around buying and selling
services and goods focused on our higher
needs
you